I mean everybody that everybody who's
doing out they're all working off the
blues no Leslie I don't wanna get caught
up in those kind of labels though you
know I don't I don't want to be whoa Kay
whoa oh he's playing no blues or he's
playing like you know R&B or solar we're
all that comes to those cages man i just
i'm not saying as it hath pleased it's
not about style who knows
i want my music to go inside the soul of
a person hello i am jimmy cata
the President of the United States thank
you very much
now I would like to do for your yeah
Elvis Presley dear Oh Margie right yeah
what look much from now you guys are
gonna be called the rail it's great does
that mean we have to let ray oh god what
I'm gonna do with you I'm sure you'll
think of something
Luca says this is self-evident you see
there it is even in that 2,000 year old
book a mechanical law it is a
self-evident truth of things which are
equal to the same thing are equal to
each other
your friends come out to your neighbors
come out to your fellow workers once and
for all let's break down the miss you're
not an American we didn't land on
Plymouth Rock Plymouth Rock landed on us
he brought honor to disobedience I
suggest you look outside that window
you've been laying down and bowing down
for 400 years I think it's time to stand
up all right break it up you got what
you wanted
now I'm not satisfied and - I only ends
up making the whole world blind
Gandhiji do you know the sacrifices
people have made never get the same
commitment again Emma the whole of India
is on the move
yes but in what direction if we obtain
our freedom by murder and bloodshed I
want no part of it you don't think I
deserve your attention I think if your
clients want to sit on my shoulders and
call themselves tall they have a right
to give it a try but there's no
requirement that I enjoy sitting here
listening to people lie you have part of
my attention you have the minimal amount
and in a mouth Laden's only two kinds of
creature good fun of the desert better
wins and gods and you're neither take it
from me for ordinary men it's a burning
fiery furnace now Dryden it's going to
be fun
it is recognized but you have a funny
sense of fun
you
you